and now four outs town outstanding ooh  boom goes the dynamite and now for  outstanding sound editing the nominees  are Richard King for the Dark Knight  Frank you'll nur and Christopher boys  for Iron Man Glen Fremantle and Tom  sayers for Slumdog Millionaire Ben Burtt  and Matthew wood for wall-e Wiley  stateman  for watching and the Oscar goes to the  Dark Knight Richard King  oh thank you  as a kid growing up in suburban Florida  I was obsessed by movies and Hollywood  seemed like was a million miles away I  never thought that I would would be here  but I'm so happy to be and thrilled to  be a part of a creative industry that  going to work is fun every day and I'd  like to thank my crew picture editor Lee  Smith mixers lorig and Gary Rizzo  bruisers Emma Thomas Chuck Robin and  Christopher Nolan who's who was very fun  to work with a very detail-oriented just  made going to work a joy and thank you  very much Chris thank you for the  Academy  you